the only place to get genuine David Pakman
show membership's is join Pakman Dotcom, accept
no substitutes.
If someone calls you and says they're offering
memberships, we don't sell memberships by
phone.
If you get a letter saying send us a check
for a membership, we don't solicit memberships
by by mail.
The one place to get a membership is join
Pakman Dotcom.
And I hope that you will over the last five
or I guess now we're on day.
Really?
Oh, what?
Today is actually the beginning of day seven
of the Biden presidency.
We have seen a dramatic change in what press
briefings look like.
Kayleigh McEnany, who was Trump's press secretary,
was replaced with Jen Psaki, who is Joe Biden's
press secretary.
And for the most part, she answers the questions
that are asked.
She's still a press secretary.
When it's not advantageous to answer, she
won't.
But we're actually getting valuable information
about what's going on with Joe Biden.
Now, one of the additional characters that
has sort of come to prominence during the
Jen Psaki era is the son of Fox and Friends
anchor Steve Doocy named Peter Doocy.
Peter Doocy is Steve Ducey's son, and he,
I guess, is now part of the White House press
corps.
And he has made it a habit to ask the most
aggressive question he can and good for him,
except that it's not good journalism.
They're just sort of really dumb gotcha type
questions.
And hilariously, Jen Psaki actually called
Peter Doocy Steve do see a couple of times.
So this is like a whole little subculture
thing that's developing in the White House
press briefings.
And I want to look at some clips with you.
It really does seem as though Peter Doocy
is trying to make himself known as the tough
guy who's willing to hold Jen Psaki accountable,
except it just implodes hilariously every
time.
Here is one clip from when Dr. Fauci joined
Jen Psaki last week at her first or second
press briefing.
And Peter Doocy asked Dr. Fauci about rumors
that Amazon was now offering to get involved
with covid-19.
And right wingers say it's bias.
Amazon refused to help Trump.
Now they want to help Joe Biden in order to
make him look good.
Here is Dr. Fauci asked about that by Peter
Doocy.
Yeah.
How helpful would it have been to Amazon got
involved with the federal response to Code
19 for fighting?
And you know, about any plans or discussions
I had of yesterday that I don't think I could
answer that question.
I'd be waving my hands about that.
Sorry.
Well, you know, one of the new things in this
administration, if you don't know the answer,
I don't guess just say you don't know the
answer.
Yeah.
Yes.
Now, of course, this has nothing to do with
Dr. Fauci.
Peter Doocy is.
I get it, Peter.
D.C. is implying Amazon has political motivations
for not helping Trump and offering to help
Biden.
That's if it's true that Amazon didn't offer
to help Trump.
I don't know.
We don't know the answer to that.
But the questions about Amazon's involvement
during a prior administration either need
to go from to someone from that administration
who was working on supply and logistics, which
Dr. Fauci was not, or to Amazon.
The idea that that's a question for Dr. Fauci
is hilarious.
And Peter Doocy tried the same thing with
Jen Psaki, the White House press secretary.
The question is, did the transition officials
know for yesterday that they wanted to get
involved in such a meaningful way?
Not that I'm aware of.
I'm happy to check.
I mean, when the reporting came out, I asked
the question and I think internally and, you
know, what was conveyed to me and I don't
think we discussed this yesterday was that
we've had a lot of outreach, some privately,
some publicly from a range of businesses and
private sector entities.
And we certainly welcome that and will be
considering all of those offers and what makes
the most sense and our plans and proposals,
because there are some Trump officials saying
they were never offered help from Amazon.
And so they're essentially saying they think
this was a political call, friends, until
we were to trying the balance.
But you're saying I'm not aware of the timeline
of when Amazon reached out.
That sounds like a question for Amazon to
me, and that's exactly right.
Did they reach out to the Trump administration?
I don't know.
Ask the Trump administration or ask Amazon.
It's not really a question for Joe Biden.
Why are they interested now?
That's a question for Amazon.
It's not a question for Dr. Fauci or for Jen
Psaki.
Then he goes to, isn't it divisive that there
will be impeachment?
I'm sorry.
I told you I was going to ask you.
I just skipped over.
Go ahead.
I'll tell you now.
So President Biden wants a theme of his presidency
to be unifying the country.
Does he think that Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer should drop a potentially.
Divisive Senate impeachment trial.
The answer should be the same every single
time Joe Biden will play no role whatsoever
in the impeachment trial, he is not going
to try to get anyone in the Senate to do anything.
He is not going to try to influence anyone
in the Senate not to do anything.
Joe Biden was not in the Senate when the House
voted on impeachment.
Joe Biden is not in the Senate now.
It would be inappropriate for Joe Biden to
exert any influence one way or the other.
He will remain totally out of it.
That is the exact right answer, and that's
the answer that should be given every single
time.
Peter Doocy then also asked, why didn't Joe
Biden wear a mask on, quote, federal lands
during the inauguration at the Lincoln Memorial?
Ahead, why weren't President Biden, all members
of the Biden family, mass at all times on
federal lands last night if he signed an executive
order that mandates masks on federal lands
at all at the inaugural Rose Memorial?
Yes, and of course, they basically were wearing
masks most of the time.
Masks did come off at one point for some photographs.
It was just Biden's family together, probably
a bad look.
But the idea that this is a gotcha question,
when the Trump administration's mishandling
of the virus led to probably more than 100000
unnecessary deaths.
It's just ridiculous.
Here is Peter Doocy trying to call out Joe
Biden for putting in place travel restrictions
now after previously calling Donald Trump's
travel restrictions xenophobic.
And just one more about the announcement he
made at the top of the travel restrictions
when President Trump was imposing travel restrictions
in March, specifically on China.
Then candidate Biden called it xenophobia
and fear mongering.
So now President Biden is putting travel restrictions
on people coming in from other countries.
What words we use to describe.
Now, this is just not true.
This has been repeated ad nauseum.
Biden said it was xenophobic.
He said the travel restrictions were xenophobic.
The truth is that Biden supported covid travel
restrictions and he called Trump xenophobic,
but not for the covid travel restrictions.
This is one of those where you if you repeated
enough times, it sort of becomes true.
But Joe Biden didn't say the covid restrictions
were xenophobic.
He supported them.
And he also said that Donald Trump was xenophobic
for other reasons.
Yesterday, Joe Biden, interestingly, deliberately
picking Peter Doocy, knowing that Doocy asks
him sandbagging questions.
Check this out.
Deucy sort of asks a weird question about
shutting down the virus and Joe Biden handles
it perfectly well.
Now, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know he always asked me tough questions
and he always has an edge to them, but I like
him anyway.
So go ahead and answer the question.
Thank you, Mr. President.
So you just have it.
You think within three weeks or so will be
at the point where there are a million vaccines
per day?
But it seems like I think we'll get there
before that.
I said I hope I misspoke.
I hope we'll be able to increase as we go
along to get to the million five a day.
That's my, my my hope.
And then my follow up to that would be now
that you're president and you're saying there
is nothing we can do to change the trajectory
of the pandemic in the next several months,
what happened to two months ago when you were
talking declaratively about I'm going to shut
down the virus, I'm going to shut down the
virus, but not I never said I'd do it in two
months.
I said it took a long time to get here.
It's going to take a long time to beat it.
And so we have millions of people out there
who are who have the virus.
We're just for the first day, I think, correct
me if I'm wrong, I've been doing other things
this morning speaking with foreign leaders.
But one of the things I think this is one
of the first days that the numbers actually
come down, the number of deaths and the number
on a daily basis and the number of hospitalizations,
etc.
It's going to take time.
It's going to take a heck of a lot of time.
And we still have, as Dr. Fauci constantly
points out, it's one thing when we have mass,
how can I say politely mass disregard of the
warnings about not wearing masks and wearing
masks and and social distancing and failure
to social distance and people getting together
and holidays in ways that weren't recommended,
etc..
We see first thing that happens is we see
the the number of infections go up and you
see the hospitalizations go up.
Then you see the deaths go up.
So remember that as reported yesterday, 69
percent of the country approves of Joe Biden's
week one handling of the pandemic.
But regardless, Joe Biden not phased, not
thrown off by Peter Doocy there.
And I think this is how do is.
Going to try to become more well-known during
this presidency, I think that the OAS report,
or I think it's own Chanel areon, also tried
to become known for asking certain types of
questions during the Trump administration.
The problem was she was very, very bad over
at that news conference, apologize for that.
She was very, very bad at asking the questions.
And so she never really became super well
known of deucy seems better, at least at formulating
the questions.
And he may very well end up becoming relatively
known for dropping tough questions on Jen
Psaki and Joe Biden.
But so far, the questions are all quite dumb.